well this you have to see to believe or
maybe not donald trump wants you and me
taxpayers to pay for his bogus special
master that never should have even been
granted so let's back up and i'll tell
you what's going on
business insider headline trump wants to
split the cost of the special master
with the government
but the doj wants him to pay for it
uh a judge granted trump's request for a
special master but the doj has appealed
the decision now remember judge eileen
cannon granted trump's request for a
special master a special master would
take control of all the documents seized
from trump's mar-a-lago would review
them and would see
are there documents here that shouldn't
be part of the fbi investigation because
they are in some way privileged are
there documents here that shouldn't be
part of the investigation maybe because
they contain medical information or
whatever the case may be that granting
of a special master
has been found by legal experts who have
weighed in to be absolutely absurd and
raises major questions about judge
eileen cannon fine but then we get to
the question of who's going to pay for
this a new court filing shows the two
sides disagree
over who should pay for the special
master the government said trump as the
party requesting the special master
should bear the cost but trump wants the
government to split it with him
even though the doj does not agree
the filing also outlined disagreements
between the government and trump's legal
team regarding how the entire special
master process would unfold no surprise
there trump's team proposed to split
evenly the professional fees and
expenses of the special master and any
professionals support staff and expert
consultants engaged at the masters
request but the justice department has
already started reviewing the c's
materials doesn't want a special master
appointed and disagreed
the government's position is that as the
party requesting the special master
plaintiff should bear the additional
expense of the special master's work
um
this actually could be so hypothetical
if judge eileen cannon
is coming around to the fact that her
decision to grant the special master was
the wrong decision if she's coming
around to that
this could be a way to get out because
we know trump doesn't pay for stuff and
the decision could be made
uh you pay for all of it or there's no
special master
that would be one thing that to look at
that would be interesting but the whole
premise of trump's argument
uh and the judge ruling with him
is that his documents must be protected
and sorted through
the government doesn't have such a
concern if the government believes that
they were authorized to obtain the
documents that everything was done on
the up and up all of those things and
and uh indeed remember that classified
and top secret documents
those aren't trump's documents those are
government documents if trump wants to
make the case they are his documents and
they shouldn't be released and all these
different things
it should be him it should be he
who actually ends up paying for it and
we don't know if that's actually the
direction it's going to go it doesn't
make sense that trump gets to dictate
to the government
what of its own documents because
remember as
william barr has said this
um who else has said so many republicans
have now said these aren't trump's
documents these are government documents
these are the people's documents for
lack of a better term it doesn't make
sense that trump gets to tell the
government what they need to do with
their own documents and then they also
pay for that it is trump who has to get
to do that he wants the special master
he should have to pay for it it doesn't
make sense to keep deferring to him in
this way now what's the strategy
the strategy is just a delay
that's the strategy and it's a
well-known legal strategy
you often
it applies
often in criminal trials where most
criminal defense attorneys will tell you
the longer we can delay the better for
everybody number one and this is i sort
of say this tongue-in-cheek but also not
the more motions to delay that a lawyer
can file and succeed with
the more the lawyer gets to bill all
else being equal and continue extending
extending extending and listen at the
end of the day yeah lawyers want to make
money oh the bonus show where you want
to make money yeah sometimes people want
to make money okay but that's not to
suggest lawyers would unethically do
that there's also the legal explanation
which the lawyers have told me which is
the longer you can delay a criminal case
witnesses might die
witnesses recollection becomes less
accurate
documents might be lost evidence might
be misplaced and it generally speaking
favors defendants to delay delay delay
in criminal trials laws might change
this applies more to like white collar
and even though generally speaking
the way you were prosecuted is based on
what the law was at the time it's still
not going to hurt you if the law changes
in a way that is favorable all these
different things can happen so that's
the strategy here delay as much as
possible period and this is it's like a
kid trying to delay bedtime well you
know
i need to use the bathroom and i'm
getting thirsty and oh i don't know i
need to check what's my lunch tomorrow
and now i'm hungry and then oh well i
gotta brush my teeth again it's the same
type of thing and now trump wants you to
pay for it and hopefully that is
rejected